tally est ce que vous allez allez
rencontrer les vrais plus vraiment qui
travaillent dans les écoles bien cher
encore à tous les jours cette semaine
comme ça je suis reconnu maintenant les
enseignants vient de le voir encore hier
j'étais je faisais des courses chez un
enseignant qu'il me voit en parler cette
situation ne pensait pas du test avec
cette réponse le monsieur le ministre il
vous demander si vous alliez sur le
terrain dans les écoles dans les classes
et leur seule réponse est que pendant
que vous avez fait vos courses de l'iran
contre une enseignante
j'imagine que si vous aviez une
meilleure réponse à donner vous l'auriez
données donc c'était votre meilleure
réponse une entrevue avec le ministre
l'éducation qu'on a fait ici lundi
dernier qui a fait beaucoup beaucoup
réagir dans les milieux de l'éducation
avec une clause de whiting où cette prof
d'éducation physique à l'école
secondaire louis joseph papineau c'est
dans saint-michel à montréal bonsoir
monsieur white un bonsoir monsieur roy
j'ai regardé cette vidéo tout à leurs
skis d'abord on premier constat la votre
gymnase fait dur le toit tombe
littéralement sur les étudiants
vous exagérez même pas l'état de
certaines écoles est déplorable
effectivement puis le la preuve annick
déjà après un reportage cet après midi
comme son squelette est déjà dans nos
gymnastes pour faire des tests alors un
nom c'était c'est vraiment assez réelle
et puis c'est ce qu'on vit à chaque jour
là des morceaux qui nous tombent
littéralement sur la tête et racontez
moi comment votre démarche vous avez
entendu cette entrevue là est la réponse
du ministre vraiment vous a mis hors de
vous quand je lui demandais allez-vous
dans des classes quand elle j'allais les
voir les professeurs dans leur milieu
et là c'est ça qui a fait péter le
bouchon lâché besoins distincts sait pas
écouter sam sam a outré ja je t'amène
gégéne et c'est ce que je disais
certaines personnes nous les enseignants
en forme c'est ces gens là qui
deviennent men est d'attendre une
réponse comme ça c'est cet agenda
écoutez
il n'y a jamais répondu à votre question
qui rencontre des enseignants à
l'épicerie c'est pas de réponse que
j'attendais j'aurais aimé qu'ils disent
que tu as rencontré il ya pas longtemps
ou quelques jours avant un groupe
d'enseignants dans une école ou un
comité d'enseignants mais c'est pas le
cas et je lisais dans le journal
aujourd'hui que ça fait 222 jo qui n'a
pas rencontré des enseignants dans les
écoles et vous vous nous montrez sur
votre vidéo vous avez mis en ligne sur
les réseaux sociaux vous nous montrez
donc l'état de ce plafond de gymnase on
va peut-être le voir là mais au-delà de
ça va au delà de ça bien au delà
vous êtes un collège privé à côté de
chez nous dans saint-michel ils sont
super bien équipé et l'école publique
souffrent énormément là et oui c'est
évident on pisse et projets chez nous le
mois j'ai je me suis occupé de mon école
parce que je la came c'est pareil à
saint henri c'est pareil partout totaux
dans le quartier saint-michel montréal
ans c'est la même chose
oui les les les gymnases les locaux sont
en dégradation d'école sainte-lucie
maintenant qui a aménagé dans notre
école depuis 1999 que le que les
ministères c'est que cette école de la
moisissure et là ils viennent ça fait un
an que des cossins suscite à l'intérieur
de nos murs et il n'y a rien de fait
encore ça peut bouger ses on va là-bas
les yeux rien que bouge encore alors oui
c'est
une situation de dégradation incroyable
et quand le ministre me disait la
semaine dernière parce que je parlais de
68 professionnels orthopédagogue tu fois
que la commission scolaire de montréal a
dû couper qu'il m'a répondu ce parce que
la commission scolaire de montréal
administre mal c'est pas de notre faute
comment vous réagissez à ça écoutez on
est mal moi je vais pas juger si la
commission scolaire en mini ce mal je
suis j'ai pas les qualifications pour
décider sort ce que je sais c'est que ça
fait vingt-quatre un mois que je suis
dans cette école là j'ai jamais vu
personne du ministère j'ai vu le l'état
des lieux se dégrader année après année
est ce que je constate c'est que là bas
on l'a vu sur la vidéo les plafonds
commence à descendre et ça m'inquiète
alors est-ce que c'est mal géré moi je
crois c'est l'hypothèse que j'ai mais
c'est que le ministère de l'éducation
n'a jamais eu d' enveloppe budgétaire
pour le parc immobilier d'accord la
commission scolaire de montréal ou pour
d'autres comme ce calage j'ai vu que
marguerite beau marguerite bourgeoys
c'est la même chose
point de lille c'est la même chose
ailleurs il ya des sommes d'argent
nécessaires pour mettre les écoles à
niveau n'existe pas tout simplement
c'est pas comme si les intérêts de
l'argent caché les comme chose scolaire
plutôt que de rénover les écoles il ya
évidemment et on n'a pas depuis des
années de ce dossier là d'ailleurs
évidemment un manque d'argent a terminé
à monsieur whiting est ce que vous
aimeriez un jour voir un ministre allait
se promener dans une vraie école dans
votre quartier par exemple
ben moi personnellement je les invite à
me rencontrer à l'école très bien le oui
j'aimerais ça j'aimerais j'aimerais que
pas seulement des ministres mais des des
gens aussi je pense que les gens du
milieu d'affaires et déjà qu'ils
pourraient investir dans les écoles
c'est notre avenir
on va continuer à suivre ce grand
dossier de l'éducation on sait qu'on est
en plein milieu d'une négociation vers
aussi les rations seront touchés au pas
dans les classes un autre sujet très
sensible également sur waiting merci à
beaucoup nous avons parlé sur un
plaisant à la prochaine à lui
salut